[Applaus]
[Musik]
links
[Applaus]
[Musik]
claudia schmied ist seit 20 jahren maler
glenz größter fan
seit einem jahr ist sie auch ihre beste
freundin
[Musik]
wie kommt es dass ein fast vergessen
gegangener weltstar dank einer schweizer
konditorin zurück auf die große bühne
fand
dieser film erzählt die geschichte einer
außergewöhnlichen freundschaft
[Musik]
claudia schmied hat vor gut einem jahr
alle ihren mut zusammengenommen ihren
job gekündigt und ihre eigene kleine
firma gegründet
mit ihren cakes hat sie erfolg der
größte konnte der preisgekrönten
konditorin ist globus delikatessen steht
besonders viel arbeit an helfen die
mutter und eine freundin in der
backstube aus claudia ist eine die
anpackt mit viel einsatz hat sie ihre
leidenschaft zum beruf gemacht ihren
keller hat sie eigenhändig in ein bug
atelier umgebaut
mittlerweile baxi cakes und torten für
die ganze schweiz
doch in claudias leben gibt es noch eine
zweite große leidenschaft
in einer ecke ihrer backstube steht eine
art altar für marine jugend- musik- und
das auto ist offen
doch claudia ist mehr als bloß ein
normaler fan
es kommt einem fast so vor als habe sie
ihr idol marla glen vergöttert werden
können bin ich so info und im
schießstand ist das holzkreuz sie und
dann habe ich mich mal generell habe ich
mir sagst du insgesamt sehr auf die
wenig dampf so oft das schult bereich
ist aber ich sehe aber oft bleibt das
heißt es aus der fdp kam auf bühne und
den heimischen see sagt ich dass das
ritz und ich meine nicht dass das auf
der bühne jetzt ein james kam ich würds
mir schenken
jetzt lockt mit am nächsten morgen hat
sie denn da
nachdem hacker aber das ist jetzt aber
es wurde und dennoch nicht zu erfahren
dass mehrere angebote zum das
verlagshaus philipp schwieriger weil
egal zahlen für das uns jetzt mehr
hakkani und millionäre liegt mir dass
ich zu dem hobby bezahlt eigentlich als
geschenke über marla glen aufgewachsen
in einer künstlerfamilie in chicago mit
33 nach europa gekommen eine
außergewöhnliche sängerin mit
unverwechselbare stimme
er hätte lieber von ihrem debütalbum
wurde anfang der 90er jahre zum
welterfolg der androgyne musicstar
erhielt dafür dreimal gold einmal platin
doch der musikalische erfolg zahlt es
sich für sie nicht aus das musikbusiness
war hart jeder wollte an ihr
mitverdienen
sie fühlte sich hintergangen und
betrogen
[Applaus]
ich sollte in einem palast leben heute
aber ich habe viele verträge nie gesehen
ich weiß nicht wer all diese geschäfte
abgeschlossen hat sie behauptete nie
sein großer star mit eigenen rechten
sie haben meine rechte gestohlen wir
sind ziemlich von rechnung spreche
moment das moderne sklaverei ich fühle
mich wie eine sklavin der neuzeit
heute lebt marla glen in einer einfachen
wohnung im deutschen oppenheim
sie hat all ihr geld verloren sie war
ganz unten
ihnen ging es schlecht damals da haben
sie verdammt recht ich fühlte mich
wieder betrogen wieder ausgetrickst
wieder war ich die dumme mal dass sie
psychisch angeschlagen war
thomalla via facebook in die welt hinaus
in ihrer not begann sie mit einer ihr
unbekannten frau in der schweiz zu
chatten und denn das ist denn sich den
minirock 27 jahren nur ein viertel vor
sieben jahren habe ich dort können die
fans die hope for you und eine schere an
private finance watch over me
aber denke ich könnte dir mal ein haus
das ich habe dass das ich dass wir im
moment einfach dank noch damit die flut
vormalige die schlacht der schlachten
sagen wir über die muss sie muss doch
mal irgendwie das mini itx iz runde
alles mit jockey asse probiert und nur
so ausweglos schnapsidee und bin habe
ich dachte ja im januar wird sich so
schön mit schnee und so habe ich dann
endlich der sich 1982 weil die affäre
weil wenn sie jeden tag an ihrem laptop
oder gar nicht wissen wir dass sie ist
facebook aber wenn sie die räder
durchdrehen nicht heute deshalb ist eine
u23 dagegen natürlich das ist ein mini
maxi und der jemen ist ein kristall so
grassiert
meine erste reaktion war okay da stellt
mir wieder jemand einer falle der denkt
es sei einfacher marla glen ranzukommen
denn schließlich wurde schon oft
betrogen warum haben sie ihre meinung
geändert
ich hab sie nicht geändert ich habe eine
chance gepackt
also setzte sich mahler glen in den zug
und fuhr in die schweiz nach erfolgter
am albis
mit einem mulmigen gefühl im bauch
[Musik]
natürlich hatte ich etwas angst jena um
all die anderen betrogen hat lasst es
mich jetzt ein letztes mal versuchen
einen realen menschen in mein leben zu
lassen und freunde zu werden
es ging nicht um marla glen sondern um
mich als person darum wer ich bin als
mensch
ich fürchtete sie könnte mich wie alle
anderen nur einladen um mich zu
hintergehen viele daten schreckliche
dinge
was war ihre hoffnung dass ich endlich
eine freundin
auf der suche nach einer freundin reiste
maler damals ins ungewisse
heute ist es für sie längst wie ein
nachhausekommen claudia und maria sind
zwei sehr unterschiedliche menschen mit
völlig anderen leben und doch fühlt man
dass sich hier zwei gefunden haben
dieses mal ist maler aus einem
besonderen grund zu claudia gereist
[Musik]
es ist ein ganz großer tag für sie
claudia feiert ihren 38 geburtstag und
das ein jahr jubiläum ihrer firma heute
steigt die große party
die klage sei nicht sparen die gefahr
dass es bereit ist zumutbar band gerade
auch aus der schweiz
und ja jetzt die überraschung für die
gäste ist ein exklusivkonzert von marla
glen auch für sie ist es kein auftritt
wie jeder andere
es ist fast als wäre ich ein teil der
familie
es ist ein familiäres geschehen nicht
ein auftritt gefiel die party steigt im
steakhouse mad men städten für claudia
und ihre firma ein wichtiger anders denn
nicht nur ihre freunde auch alle ihre
kunden sind eingeladen
ich freue mich erhoben dass sie ihr
leben ist so zahlreich zum geburtstag
unzählige ich mir das eine sind ihr all
die anderen reform mit golfer dass ich
stolz auf sein dream come true und darum
ist es wirklich mir das über großes
anliegen
[Musik]
fantastic maler grillen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
duisburg
auf der bühne ist marla glen
hochprofessionell in der freizeit geben
sich mahler und claudia hin und wieder
wie kindsköpfe doch ja wir spielten lese
ich spielte laser tag und kind hat mich
getötet andere frauen gehen zusammen
shoppen hier aber macht die verrückt ist
nun ich bin keine frau doppler das war
ein fettnapf maler selber sieht sich
nicht als frau er schon als mann oder
als ungeschlechtlich darum nennt sie
sich selbst auch einfach die kleinen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
fast 20 jahre altersunterschied liegen
zwischen claudia und maler im alltag
jedoch wirkt claudia wie die ältere der
beiden und wie die vernünftigere sie
sagt wo es langgeht sie packt an
sie steht mit beiden beinen auf dem
boden und im leben
hanna klein wirkt manchmal wie ein
großes kind das nicht erwachsen werden
will
das ungleiche duo fällt auf auch im
einkaufscenter in affoltern am albis und
speziell wochen redet denn es muss
wirklich die person sie
[Musik]
den wein musst du den ausweis zeigen
ich hoffe nicht aber du siehst junge aus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ist war zu besuch wird es hinter kleinen
küche von claudia und ihrem freund bert
ehm maler soll heute zum ersten mal im
leben von dessen ihre spezial kartoffeln
dürfen dabei nicht fehlen
auch kollegin corinna ist eingeladen
man spürt dass innerhalb eines jahres
eine große vertrautheit gewachsen ist
eine freundschaft die beide verändert
hat offene schwierig
also wenn ich denke was sie alles klappt
und immer noch da ist und wenn es um das
stehaufmännchen habe ich ein rennen der
indy spielt sie kommen könne trocken
durchaus zusammen und sind wieder
aufgestanden gemacht haben denn wie auch
viel mut und die probleme aber den
selber hätte sind also ideal da ein von
der familie
und das ist okay danke ja sicher die
module bieten sich okay
es macht spaß
sie war mir gegenüber skeptisch und ich
war hier gegenüber skeptisch aber wir
hatten die verrückt haltung den mut und
das herz um es einfach zu tun
wir entdeckten dass wir uns darin einig
sind wie machen es einfach die managerin
am tisch aber ist claudia wer sie kennt
ist nicht überrascht dass sie auch in
sachen marler mit anpackt die konditorin
ist jetzt mal als buchhalterin um ihre
desolate nen finanzen ins lot und den
musicstar zurück auf die bühne zu
bringen
die unterlagen geschrieben
und ja es ganz ordentlich stativ der
papiere lag sie im schnitt gar dazu ihre
stärke und da kann ich sie gut
unterstützen das buch mit seinen zieht
und ja also der umstürze man lade deine
sache kompliziert aus aber dass sie
vielleicht gefahr läuft ja sooo genau
dass ich so dass sie weiß dass ich ja
sie vertragen sie weiß dass ich damit
truck ich weiß dass ich saubere linie
firma aufbaut rund um das ich weiß wie
die woche oder funktioniert und dass sie
mir die papiere auf vertrauen und das
sogar kunden genau und den verbrechen
doch der kommt sagt dass musicals
gekümmert und das dass der bus dass man
auch im vorfeld auszahlt wird
sind alle triebe und so kann er ihre
existenz einer nachhaltig erhalten
bleiben das konzert machen
wie hier in der müller und sie können
bei bern der soundcheck vor dem konzert
heute steht claudia nicht mehr als
fällen vor der bühne sondern sie gehört
backstage mit zum team
während claudia sich um die finanzen
kümmert managed ingo schöneberg die tour
auch er stammt nicht aus dem
musikbusiness
er führt eine fahrschule in oppenheim
[Musik]
hat mahler gesehen vor diesem jahr bevor
sie claudia kennen gelernt hat und ich
kann nur sagen das ist wirklich eine
positive situation für maler weil sie
eben hier vertrauen fassen kann und das
ist im moment das wichtigste das man ja
auch dieses vertrauen entgegenbringt so
dass sie nicht das gefühl hat dass
irgendetwas hinter dem rücken passiert
was zweifelsohne in der vergangenheit
geschaut
das konzert ist ausverkauft in kürze
erscheint eine neue cd
marla glen aus chicago ist zurück dank
der freundschaft und der hilfe von
claudia schmied ich mag es wenn karl
damit läuft alles reibungslos
alles ist klar wenn sie hier ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]